[Music]
Oh Monday morning that didn't flow watch
the garage official trailer yes it's a
reboot that's also a sequel I guess it
takes place on the same timeline as the
2004 film that's because the other one
was called grudge hey guys follow us on
the Stardust app over there with your 30
second reaction reviews for films TV
shows and or trailers posted daily cover
a lot of things that we don't cover on
this channel whenever we catch up on
whatever is new first to the opinion you
know what I'm trying to say it's
completely free to download users do
[Music]
yes it is yeah they got it they gotta
move donkeys Josh for this from a
producer same right
[Music]
[Music]
we cut this is detective Muldoon
this is Peter Spencer something happen
to be important
it is
[Music]
oh nice hey gender reversal Oh
3r yeah that's nice okay yeah man get
that John show in there you know The
Grudge was a movie that definitely left
an impact on me when I first saw I even
saw you on as well I like about like Jew
I'm a little bit more I did it in mind
The Grudge sequel that already came out
you know whatever at this I think this
trailer is better than whatever that
ring movie is they came out a couple
years ago that everyone seemed to skip
out on oh yeah rings rings yeah that one
is this kind of feels like a straight to
DVD movie all the gimmicks seem like the
exact same gimmicks it just looks better
like yeah right down to the hole because
that's what happened with sarah michelle
gellar where she's washing her hair and
the hand comes out in the Sarah Michelle
Gellar won that they could have cheated
it better and then here it's the same
exact thing but but it looks better it
looks more eerie and that's what most of
these scared gimmicks look like but
least one of the teases that we got this
this feels like a lower budget then what
yeah it doesn't even though this is a
more recent edition it's film quality
looks actually like it's a much lower
budget film weirdly this looked like it
yeah it looks like a different kind of
movie to me and this trailer took me by
a weird pleasant surprise because yeah I
do agree and I am kind of concerned by
the fact that all the gags appear to be
the same gags I was just intrigued by
the fact that they didn't go with like a
teenage cast for this one or or like a
very young trendy cast it's like they
got the woman from Andy to be the lead
and like the idea that this is some kind
of weird police investigation all these
more adult characters are dealing with
the most new thing to me looked like the
corpse they find in the car if that's
related to any of this because it's not
in the house and that seems new I kind
of wonder if this is they got a guy
who's made I think it's called in the
eyes of my mother which was like an
actual film film so it seems like an
interesting choice to get that guy to do
this and it looks like they are aiming
for something a bit more dramatic and a
bit more weighty with this and I don't
think that's bad I just di i won
how those same gags are gonna fit into
this new police procedural because I
felt like I was watching a trailer for a
Saw movie it's something that moved a
little bit slower and a little bit more
based on tension there are things about
it that I do like like I'm a fan of the
franchise overall but I'd say that this
looks like the similar thing just a
little bit of a lower budget I don't
know if that'll actually be a bad thing
because it doesn't seem like it says in
your face about everything it seems like
there probably to do a lot more tension
and build doesn't look as blockbuster II
but it yeah that's probably word I'm
mainly looking for but it's still you
know is the jump-scare jate horror film
that arguably should be not every horror
film needs to be the lighthouse or
hereditary or something you know yeah I
mean Jake horror is it some flavor I
feel like I don't know where we are in
the wave of haunted house demon movies I
feel like we've been here for a long
time I don't know I guess I'm kind of
rooting for this but it seems like a
little out of time in place I don't know
how this will hit because it's a January
3rd movie yeah there's that and it's
also dude I don't know how much people
are craving this flavor of horror which
maybe is why they put it in January
something like that I like I'm intrigued
by everybody who's involved again and I
feel like this has the potential to be
and alright Philip I think what it could
really benefit from is a red band
trailer sure yeah especially with that
our rating with Sam Raimi being a
producer makes me flash to the countless
violent to Sam Raimi films we've seen
before there could be like a real punch
to all the violence that occurs in this
film I think this could truly be like
visually disturbing in a gory fantastic
way I think a red band would get it
could help really demonstrate what can
really distinguish this from the other
ones even though there is that police
procedural quality that is represented
in this trailer the other ones are still
investigative types they might not be
police procedural but that's still an
investigation mystery and I just got
different profession leading the cause
here John show being here that's cool
Jay that's cool is it cool people to be
in here I mean bashir let's do it yeah
none it seems like all the right pieces
are in place here I was kind of hoping
that we could guess in the feels like so
different or distinguished silly ripping
or something I'm not sure exactly what I
was looking for here I feel like I got a
percentage of that just not a hundred
percent like I got like a 65 percent so
feel like the excitement of this trailer
relies on whatever things you loved or
liked about the previous installments
already I feel like that's where the
main hook of this is and I'm like you
know figures like especially to cap it
off with the shower bit I don't lay out
it out or not just a remake to me at
that point I'm like it's the same scares
again yeah and I feel like there's a
certain element of this concept there's
always gonna be the same movie kind of
each time around is with different
locations or different set pieces
because how many ways can you do though
when somebody dies in the grip of a
powerful rage in a house and you go into
that house they're gonna kill you like
you know how many ways can you repackage
that and still call it the grudge
alright guys well are you excited for
this remake up the grudge trailer do it
for you you think it's an actual gonna
be a good movie or do you think it's
perhaps a a trailer that was cut really
well out of it not so great movie which
one do you think it's gonna be you guys
can subscribe for the rejects click that
notification bell hey we gave a page for
the day show I did a video with Amy
castle that got blocked on YouTube never
allowed to see the light of day on this
platform there was a patron today shot
some man named Andrew Nickerson and I
figured I just roll that footage for you
guys to end this video right here let's
get a picture of the day shoutouts do it
to a man named Andrew Nickerson look Amy
I'm gonna need your skills here for a
second can can you just say here hold on
let me let me get really clever here do
it sensuous synonym okay
yes can you just say a voluptuous tone
yes
the name Andrew Nickerson so that way he
will feel like his shout out has been
worth it as opposed to me say some dumb
shoutout
hi Andrew Nickerson sure
hi Angie Nickerson sexy how you doing
okay next guy you date you better work
on your sexy calming voice for it okay
that's not gonna fly
hi engine dickerson